während bei uns hier in deutschland also
die regeln angezogen werden alles
verschärft wird lockert es sich gerade
wieder auf mallorca denn dort sinken die
infektionszahlen und dort für ist für
uns jan frederik erlangt hausen denn
heute soll dort wieder die basis öffnen
am ballermann hallo jan frederik hallo
wie wenig und viel los ist denn jetzt
bei dir ja du hast es ja gerade gesagt
die war's dürfen öffnen das gilt für die
bierstraße und die schinkenstraße nur
wenn man sich hier mal um guckt dann ist
alles leer
wir können hier zumal zum beispiel nach
links schwenken also die ganzen bars
sind weiterhin geschlossen das obwohl
sie heute seit dem 15 oktober wieder
öffnen dürfen das gleiche zeichnet sich
ab in der schinkenstraße auch da ist
alles zu das einzige einzige lokal das
hier heute geöffnet hat ist das eher
dumpf hier zu meiner rechten auch da ist
es sehr bescheiden das publikum mich
sehr jetzt gerade vier gäste die aktuell
da sind natürlich ist es neben sie
sorgen aber dennoch wären jetzt
normalerweise mehrere hundert leute da
und somit ist es ein absolut trauriges
und erschreckendes bild das sich hier
abzeichnet
und warum machen nicht alle geschäfte
wieder auf na ja das liegt zum einen
daran oder eigentlich ist es generell
grund dass mallorca so fühlt es sich an
wie eine geister insel ist hier das gar
nichts los entsprechend fehlen natürlich
auch die deutschen touristen und somit
lohnt es sich auch nicht für die lokale
wieder aufzumachen die haben natürlich
erhebliche kosten personal
versicherungen für sie wäre es natürlich
daneben ein absolutes minusgeschäft
und wie ist die entscheidung der
regierung angekommen jetzt wieder leben
und bars zu öffnen
ja sehr gemischt würde ich mal sagen die
einen sehen ist als positives signal als
schritt in die richtige richtung die
anderen sagen das ist absolut zynisch
jetzt das wieder zu erlauben wo alle
touristen weg sind man ist sehr
verärgert darüber
und natürlich wird man das auch
weiterhin als politisch motiviert
hingenommen als zeichen dafür dass man
den ballermann so wie er vorher
existiert hat hier auf mallorca nicht
mehr haben will
vielen dank für deine informationen
dankeschön jan frederik lang hausen aus
mallorca vielen dank mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bet schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren